my name is valence and Donna in 2015 I
film the canine of water Scott with my
samsung galaxy s5 Oh Martha Reed and in
2016 this was used to recall the least
killing of Alan sterling in bed with
Louisiana over the last decade or so the
smartphone has emerged as one of the
strongest tools for capturing police
brutality and racial injustice towards
african-americans smartphones camera are
the only thing that we have to protect
ourselves but it is a weapon that tells
the stories not to tell what happened to
me this is going to tell what took place
Americans have just witnessed this power
to document after Darnell afraser502 hit
record and held steady for 10 minutes to
capture Floyd's final words I've chosen
to limit the amount of graphic visuals
from that video and the others featured
in this piece the next day Frazier
posted her video to Facebook and then
well the world reacted
the clarity of the video and the ease of
sharing it wasn't possible a decade ago
and certainly not three decades ago when
footage of the beating of Rodney King
was captured on a Sony Handycam by
watching cell phone footage of police
brutality from the last 11 years you can
see at least a five times increase in
the resolution of images you can also
see how the proliferation of smartphones
and social media made it easier for more
and more people to capture and see the
side of the story that before was so
easily lost in 2009 cell phones were
used for one of the first times to
capture police brutality at the
Fruitvale BART transit station in
Oakland California various bystanders
captured footage of an officer shooting
22 year old Oscar Grant some views were
captured by point-and-shoot cameras like
Corinna Vargas's fujifilm finepix which
could only capture 480p footage others
with flip phones with 1.3 megapixel
cameras that shot 240p video captured
the incident at the time texting a video
cost more money and was slower over 3G
networks footage was shared with local
broadcast channels and it was later used
as evidence in the trial against
Johannes Messerly the officer who killed
grant in 2010 he was convicted of
second-degree murder from 2009 to 2015
smartphones began to take off and
cameras got increasingly better and were
more easily accessible in 2011 Apple
added the ability to get the camera from
the lock screen the video cameras got
the ability to shoot HD video and
storage increase so we could all shoot
more of it later that year Pew Research
Center started reporting smartphone
ownership 35% of Americans owned a
smartphone by the end of 2014 it had
grown to 59% that same year in New York
City the killing of Eric garner was
recorded in 720p HD by Ramsey Horta
using a samsung galaxy with a 5
megapixel camera the video was given to
the Daily News and it quickly spread
online via YouTube though Garner's death
was ruled a homicide the officer
involved was not indicted by 2015
69% of Americans had a smartphone
fade-in Santana was one of them in March
he got a new Samsung Galaxy s5 as a
present
the first thing he filmed on it officer
Michael Slager shooting and killing
Walter Scott in North Charleston South
Carolina I soon as I heard that taser
sound and I heard that there were on the
ground I decided you know to to record
and just try to get as close as possible
you know so they officer can see me yes
you know to prevent any any bad
situation we took that Santana shared
the video file with the Scott family and
it quickly made its way to TV and around
the internet the video was used as
evidence in the trial an officer Slager
was sentenced to 20 years in prison
2015 so lots of other incidents captured
this was also a very big era for mobile
video Facebook launched its live video
service and Twitter launched the ability
to easily upload video from mobile
phones from 2016 to 2019 smartphone
ownership went from 72% to 81% many
incidents were captured during this
period including Dimon Reynolds Facebook
livestream of the shooting of falando
Casteel in Minnesota then there were
multiple videos of the shooting of Alton
sterling in Baton Rouge unlimited data
plans social apps that made it easier
for sharing video and the addition of
multiple cameras on phones during this
time made recording video a reflex
action and by 2020 it was for Darnell
afraser502 George Floyd's surrounded by
police officers in front of Cup Foods in
Minneapolis and she took out her iPhone
and began filming the video in the audio
are clearer than any other because of
Frazier's proximity to the incident but
also the iPhones 12 megapixel camera
1080p resolution and video stabilization
Frazier uploaded the video to Facebook
the following day it sparked national
protests it has happened it's happened
again send it to what Will Smith has
said and said that racism didn't just
start it's just starting to be feeling
now and you can see it on sale then you
know
Changez have to come